Joe Biden is in some big trouble as his
voter base crumbles recent polls seem to
suggest that the president is rapidly
losing the support of African-Americans
Muslims and even young voters but today
Joe put on a brave face and tried to
rally the troops at a house Democrat
meeting but sleepy Joe can't ignore his
problems forever a Democrat who is in a
close battle for a crucial house seat
next week is practically begging Biden
to stay far away from his campaign Tom
swazi is telling the media that he
doesn't think it will be quote helpful
and black Chicago voters are also
letting loose on Joe Biden Biden is a
racist no Wars great policies best years
in the stock market who do you think is
done more for the black community Trump
or Biden I a't even see Biden yet I know
Trump was
Biden
everything do we G get rid of his
sleep
all right Dana I'll start with you I
mean we know that he's been losing with
the blacks and the Hispanics and the
young voters I mean don't even add in
today but how does he how does he recap
voters too and so it's interesting to
look back and think about the Democratic
Coalition that helped get him into
office and then the parts on who he's
been most focused on serving so a couple
of ideas here rich white liberals what
do they want well they want more tax
credits for their electric vehicle M
they want all the climate stuff and what
did he do today he's focused on the
squad and the concerns about supporting
Israel more than he is focused on
figuring out how to make sure that they
have some sort of proactive uh why I
should be elected to a second term but I
can't remember why type of messaging I'm
still focused on the a block um
workingclass voters Hispanic voters
swing States he's not focused on any of
those yet apparently the campaign is
having a big meeting tomorrow the Biden
campaign they're all getting together
they're going to talk about what's going
to happen going forward but at this
point you should be able to have that
message it should be clear what you want
to do and he's not able to pull together
the Coalition from before and I would
add that the other problem for him is
that especially for black men if you
read in the Washington Post for example
like two Sundays ago there's a big piece
about how black men feel about the
economy and they are much more likely
and willing to vote for a republican
than their parents or Grandparents were
so the coalitions the political
coalitions on both sides are shifting
and right now it feels like the
Republicans are on the winning side of
that yes it does so Harold if you were
advising what would you recommend they
do you take it seriously uh we've seen
some polling data and we've shown some
anecdotal things here on the show uh and
I'm sure they're seeing some of this you
can't you also have to take seriously to
Tom swasi uh in an election that will uh
a special election here in New York that
will portend I think in many ways what
we can look what we should anticipate
come November he doesn't want uh he
doesn't believe that Mr Biden would be
particularly helpful and I believe that
Republican has not invited Mr Trump in
either but put that aside Democrats need
to be need to be focused on how do you
meet voters where they are how do you
begin to talk about those things that
you've done and what you're going to do
going forward to create more ownership
and access to Capital opportunities for
communities that have been left behind
how how on Earth you going to invest in
schools and whole people to hold people
to a metric to ensure that kids are
being educated the the bread and butter
things I think are things that sometimes
Democrats lose track of they think that
every two years or four years you can
just run a get out the vote campaign
with African-Americans and they're going
to get out because they dislike or
you're going to be able to paint a
picture of the of the other side and
Donald Trump is an easy person to paint
a picture about the challenge with Trump
is so many people know him so many
people remember him uh and he does have
a relationship in the minds of a lot of
Voters with business and opportunity and
ownership uh and there's no doubt that
there's some V voters in the country
including black voters who believe that
he's been picked on and they believe
that that is something that makes him
somewhat of a folk hero if Democrats the
one glowing thing from all this you look
at the numbers where where he's going
against Biden he's down three or four
points if Democrats can get
African-American Latino voters to come
back into the four come November it's a
good thing for them but you won't do it
with a simple conventional stale get out
the vote campaign you've used over the
years you're gonna have to be creative
you have to be thoughtful you G have to
be entrepreneurial and you have to be
enterprising and how you do it and you
know what Jesse you can't say uh you
know if you ain't black uh you know you
can't use that mentality with the voters
yeah even the God isn't going for that
anymore it's the God right
th people forget judge how close the
last election was it was like 40,000
votes spread across a couple States I we
worried about Georgia Michigan
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin Georgia
population for blacks 30
3% if Biden loses just 1% of the black
vote than he did last time Georgia's
gone look at Michigan 15% black and also
3% Muslim Muslims aren't going for him
anymore plus tons of college towns and
Wisconsin Pennsylvania 12% black tons of
college towns young people Islamic
people black people Trump just needs one
or two percentage better than he did
last time and he sweeps these blue
States not just one or two
sweeps Greg
um I guess I I wonder what are the
Republicans going to do to take
advantage of this uh it's not enough to
gloat when these things happen and it's
a challenge to reach black voters
because the media runs interference
between their lies and reality so the
worse it gets for blacks the more the
media cranks up the race card so it's
hey you know you see that and they go
well you can't really vote for him over
economic issues he's racist you got to
wonder how long that's going to last
because when the white saviors on the
left keep selling you out for other
identities which is the consequence of
identity politics one day you're in then
next you're out you got to start
wondering what are the policies that
work for black white hispanic uh the
elderly the young you start thinking
maybe I should start looking at the big
picture he is prospering under one group
and it's what Michael malice calls the
awful do you know what the awful are the
ruling class affluent white Liberal
Liberal white liberals female liberals
affluent white female liberals
awful and it's so
fitting okay so much for fitting up next
Joe Biden just blew up his baloney
excuse On the Border hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else